Hello. And welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Before we get started, I just wanna say
thank you to my employer, Equinix Medal. They
provide the time and the resources for me
to invest and purchase in the show and
making sure we all have great cloud native
content to learn together.
If you wanna check out Equinix metal, there
is a code, Rawkode dash live, you can
use at metal.equinix.com.
Check it out. Have some fun.
Today, we're gonna take a look at the
captain project.
I have a great guest, Jurgen Esslsdorfer,
who is an engineer at Dynatrace and a
maintainer of the kptn project. Hello, Jurgen. How
are you?
Hi, David. Hi, everyone. Thanks. I'm good. How
are you? Yeah. Yeah. I'm very well. Thank
you. I'm looking forward to today's session and
and learning how I can use this really
cool project in my Kubernetes delivery pipeline.
I think the best way to get started
was why don't you take just thirty seconds
or a minute or, like, you know, take
as long as you want. But tell us
a little bit about you, about the project,
and then we'll we'll move on from there.
Okay. Cool.
Yeah. So my name is. I work for
a company called Dynatrace, and we started
or my role at Dynatrace, maybe I start
from there, is,
officially a technology strategist.
I joined the company about three years ago,
and I have been,
member of the Dynatrace Innovation Lab,
since then. And, yeah, a couple of years,
it maybe it was around two years ago,
we started this project. It was not called
kptn by then, but we found that we
have a lot of best practices that we
are using
when it comes to cloud native technologies, when
it comes to delivery, when it comes to
quality of software
that we are already using, and we try
to basically provide
everything
also to
to other organizations and also to our customers.
And this was the basic idea. Let's
start an open source project, and let's make
everything that we already know. Let's make it
available
for others, and let's make this
yeah.
Let let's make this a platform that everyone
can use.
And with this
project or with this idea, the kptn project
was born.
And it's now a CNCF
sandbox project, and we are pretty pretty excited
to have it. And I'm also pretty excited
to to show it or to take a
look at it today with you. Awesome. Nice.
So I believe you've got a a few
slides you wanna run us through first to
give us a little bit of a flavor,
and then we're gonna get hands on it
and kick the tires on this. So let's
pop that up. There we go.
Cool.
Okay. So let me just introduce
briefly
the kptn project, which use cases it solves
or, like, targets and which problem it solves.
If you want to take a look, there
it's captain. S h. We in Austria or
in German speaking countries, we say captain, like
the captain of a ship that was the
main
idea behind it, the the captain ship's applications.
So we will hear a couple of these
nautical terms like ship and the shipyard and
yeah. We will we will hear it anyway
in the rest of the show.
And, yeah, we also have Twitter. Yeah. So
what what is it actually,
and what what what does it do?
So we came up with this
figure here.
We we
actually target a couple of different use cases
from progressive delivery to quality gates as one
part of progressive delivery that you can use
maybe in other delivery frameworks that you might
already have in your organizations and you where
you don't want to use maybe kpten to
auto remediation when it comes to operating your
microservice applications.
These are
these fans are use cases.
And everything is built on a GitOps approach
where you just bring your configuration files, and
kpten will manage these configuration files
and will also connect to your tools. So
David already mentioned it's a control plane, a
cloud native control plane for continuous delivery and
automated operations,
and it's basically solving the problem of application
life cycle orchestration management.
So if you have health charts and if
you use helm for deployment, you can do
this with kpten as well. So kpten can
use your health charts and deploy
your
microservices for you. You can also connect it
to Argo.
You can connect it to Jenkins. We have
other integrations for
monitoring tools like Prometheus where you can use
this data for your quality checks.
You can connect it to JMeter for
load generation and performance testing. You can connect
it to Litmus KAOS for chaos engineering. So
you can connect it to a lot of
different tools.
Everything is event based.
And with this, we are very open to
to to broaden this ecosystem and to, open
up for tool integrations.
And
kpten really brings together the different tools
that you already have in your tool belt,
let's say,
and manages
continuous
or progressive delivery and automated operations for you.
So how is why did we actually start?
I said this in the beginning briefly
because we saw that a lot of different
organizations that we are working with, that we
have heard from,
they are doing a lot of manual
manual tasks
when it comes to
delivery of applications and new releases.
And these manual tasks are either in evaluating
test performances, evaluating if the new build is
actually better or if the new release is
actually better than the last one,
and also writing a lot of those pipelines.
And these pipelines, they have grown pretty large.
And, this is one
one, issue that we are also solving with
kpten.
There is no pipeline code anymore. Everything is
event based, and you just connect your different
tools, and you have very, very
small configuration
files that are for a very specific purpose.
And with this, it's very easy to change
them, update them, maintain them.
And one part is also a lot of
organizations, they spend a lot of time in
remediating the issues. They might already have some
playbooks in in place,
like,
say, Ansible playbooks or some it can be
shell scripts that just remediate an issue, but,
anyway, they have to be executed.
And here, we also bridge this gap
by from, let's say, Prometheus alert, we can
trigger
Ansible playbook or
or execute shell scripts or Python scripts
that already remediate or try to remediate issues.
So we are
with this event based
methodology,
let's say, we we can
we we can bridge these gaps.
So the first use case
yeah.
Thanks.
The first use case where I think kpten
already brings some value
is when you
start to manage
your applications with kptn.
Because kptn can already configure your monitoring, let's
say your Prometheus create the scrape jobs, create
alerting rules
in the alert manager,
create dashboards in Grafana.
We have not even yet deployed the application,
but we when we onboard the application, that's
also how we call it. It's a kpten
onboarding. It's
we have a lot of these these terms.
But when you onboard an application and you
were using Captain CLI,
that you can already use it to configure
your monitoring solutions,
set up alerts, create dashboards,
set up scrape jobs, these kind of things.
And as said, we have not even yet
started to to deploy the applications.
Yeah. I I think we'll see this later
on, so I'll just skip this one.
And the second part where it's really we
are bringing
we are bringing really a big benefit is
we have based our delivery pipelines on SRE
concepts,
SLIs and SLOs.
SLOs are short for a service level objective,
and you
or the the user of kpt and just
defines a service level objective
that can be based on response time, can
be based on the error rate,
CPU consumption, whatever.
Everything that's
queryable or that's a metric, let's say, and
you can query this from, for example, from
Prometheus,
you can define some service level objectives,
and kpten will will set up a multistage
delivery pipeline for you. And between each stage,
kptn makes sure that it evaluates
the quality of your microservice
based on the service level objective that you
have defined.
And you just define it in a YAML
file and the deployment
and the the triggering of the tests and
then the evaluation,
this is taken care of by kptn.
So for example, here, we have the shipyard
file, the SLO file, the Helm chart for
deployment,
and we can see that
the shipyard file actually, that's the it's the
complete shipyard file for a multistage pipeline. We
have dev staging production
with the quality gate. That's basically the whole
quality gates. It's the SLO file,
and you will get this automated quality gate
evaluations for each deployment that you're
triggering with kptn.
And the data is then gathered in this
example for from Prometheus,
and the tests have been executed by JMeter,
for example.
And in the
yeah. This is how it works in a
little bit more detail. We have these SLO
files and SLI files. These are you can
think of this as a library of indicators
and
how you can fetch this data,
with a PromQL query,
where you can, you you define your PromQL,
and, this is then executed when the captain
evaluates the quality gate. And you can just
reuse, let's say, the error rate here. We
just reuse the error rate in the objective
file, and we specify the error rate has
to stay lower or equal than 1%.
And
the time frame for the evaluation,
that's actually calculated by kptn since kptn can
also trigger the tests.
And kptn will trigger the tests, let's say,
g meter tests or neo load tests or
place meter, whatever you're using.
And, once the tests are finished, kptn will
be informed the tests are finished, and, it
can evaluate for this exact time frame of
the tests. We can evaluate the error rate,
response time, number of database calls. And from
this file, it will generate the total score.
Start the evaluation. It will generate the total
score
by by evaluating
this. And based on the total score, it
can then decide if it should be promoted
to the next stage or if it should
be rolled back, for example, to the previous
version if you have a blue green deployment.
Okay.
And for the third
major use case, of kptan,
this is where we, automate part of your
operations.
We call it by closed loop remediation. And
with closed loop remediation, what we really mean
is that we are constantly evaluating
if the remediation is actually
if it was successful.
So we've seen that,
organizations,
and also this is where where we started
also a couple of years.
Once there is problem or an alert coming
in, this can also be sent to kptn
as a cloud event.
Kptn can
execute remediation actions, trigger other tools, let's say,
toggling a feature flag or
triggering the rollback of a deployment or
executing some Ansible Tower playbooks.
So kpt kptr will trigger, let's say, an
Ansible Tower playbook.
Once it's finished, kpt will evaluate if this
action of Ansible Tower did actually resolve the
issue by reeval evaluating the quality gates,
reusing the SLO file that you already have
defined.
And if it's remediated,
job is basically done and alert,
can be, resolved
or the problem can be resolved. And if
it's not, remediated,
captain can take the next action, and it
can be a sequence of actions that can
be taken.
And all these actions, they are actually evaluated
if they if they remediate the issue or
not.
So for example, we have
we have one more demo application where we
send
an alert via the Prometheus alert manager.
And in the remediation file, we define two
different remediation
remediations
for one specific problem, and the problem in
this case is a response time degradation. That's
the name of the problem. This will map
to the alert of Prometheus.
So these these two, they basically have to
be they they will match.
And we'll then have a a number of
of actions. So in this case, two actions.
The first one will be executed. It's a
scaling.
Scaling is, is a built in functionality of
kptn, so we can,
basically change the values of the helm chart.
The the replica set values of the helm
chart will increase it, in this case, by
plus one or you can say by plus
10% or whatever is might be the right
action.
We'll then reevaluate
the SLO file.
We'll do this evaluation of the quality gate.
If it's remediated,
everything's fine. If not, it will go to
the next action. This is in this case,
it's the toggling of a feature flag. So
we in this case, we actually want to
disable
the a campaign of a specific campaign ID.
We can think of this like a promotional
campaign that has been initiated.
Maybe that's generating
a lot of problems for our response time.
Maybe it's
it has to has to do too much,
I don't know, database calls, for example.
So this can be also triggered.
We don't define the tooling in these files.
The tooling will be just listening for these
events. So if you want to move from
one feature flagging framework to another, you can
still use the same remediation files because what
you will do is you will just change
the the part which listens for for events
from captain.
And in this case, might be resolved or
not. We can then escalate it. We can
send all these everything that's going on, all
these cloud events also to to Slack, for
example, or just sending it to Slack when
it escalates and we could not resolve it.
Yeah. That's the that's the main or the
major three use cases.
And as said in the beginning, kpten is
built as an event based control plane
that lives in your Kubernetes cluster, and you
can send cloud events to this control plane,
and the control plane can also send
cloud events. So it re receives and sends
cloud events, and this is how the the
tool integrations are actually done. We already have
a couple of tool integrations,
and we see more and more
or we see this growing as more and
more organizations are contributing. For example, we received
a contribution for a Slack bot where you
can control
continuous delivery workflows
with a Slack bot. So you get the
whole evaluation of the quality gate directly into
Slack, and you can just accept or recheck
if
if this build
should move on to, let's say, from your
dev environment to preprode or even from preprode
to prod. So that's pretty cool.
We have a couple of
integrations here in our yeah. Contributed to to
the kpten ecosystem.
Yeah. That's
our our latest integrations,
I would say. And, yeah, maybe from this,
we already take it from there and take
a look at kptn.
If you want to also, afterwards, maybe take
a look at kptn's kptn dot s h.
That's our main website.
And,
yeah, I think we're good to Okay.
So
it does a lot.
There's there's a lot of things here. Right?
So, I mean, I'm very excited now. I
have a couple of questions. Before we get
to them, we got one from the chat.
So Adam has asked, is it possible to
use captain
outside of Kubernetes?
Yes.
So
the the when I read this question, I
can definitely answer with yes. Kptn
the applications that are managed by kpten, they
don't have to run-in Kubernetes.
But kpten itself is built to run-in Kubernetes.
But we've also built a kpten on k
three s, a very, very small kubernetes single
binary distribution that you can just run on
your small e c two instance,
and you just install kpten on k three
s there. And then it acts the control
plane acts on this e c two instance,
and you can send the cloud events to
kpten. It's just built as a couple of
microservices,
and they need
some kind of orchestration, and we we we
decided to go for Kubernetes.
But, yes, you can also use kpten for
traditional applications. It just it, I would assume
or I would just argue it works best
best with microservice architectures.
But we also see,
monolithic applications being,
quality gated by kpten.
Alright. Nice.
So on your
slide in fact, let me just pull that
back up. Let me can you go back?
Was it one slide, two slides maybe?
There. This one. Okay. So if I'm trying
to think and, you know, we'll get hands
on it in just a moment. And I'm
sure all my questions will be answered there,
but I'll throw them out anyway. It's like,
kptn runs as a control plane to monitor
pretty much everything after I get merged into
my main branch to application running in production.
Now you talk about environments and how it
can handle progressive delivery across those environments. Now
the example here is namespaces.
Could those be separate Kubernetes clusters? One for
dev staging and production?
Yes.
But only in the next version of kptn.
So we are working on this.
So today, we will we we have to
use kptn
zero dot seven dot three. That's the latest
version. And we are working on zero dot
eight. And with dot eight, it will be
possible to have
to manage different clusters in diff even in
different clouds. So then it doesn't really matter
where the cluster lives.
But right now, the control plane can manage
one cluster, and we are doing the separation
between the
the the control plane and the execution plane,
and then it will be easier.
Alright. Sweet.
Okay. Let's get started then. So if I
pull up my screen,
there we go.
We have the kptn website. People can check
that out at kptn.sh
and
there's documentation tutorials, etcetera. The tutorials, I believe,
is what we're gonna get started with today.
So
these are these just guides that anyone can
follow along
at their own time,
click star, and then you just guide it
through step by step. Right? So
are
we doing the captain filter?
It sounds exciting on Prometheus one. Right? That's
the one we're we're gonna check out. Yep.
That sounds good. And the other ones, they
are basically for different use cases.
They show you for example captain in the
box will use micro kubernetes. We also have
the guide for the captain installation on k3s
if you want to do that to connect
it to Argo CD.
So we decided to
go for tutorials. We also have a documentation
but tutorials are more
guiding you how to
to follow
the
the the concepts of kpt and how to
use them to
to the best.
So here's the branch I want then for
my multi cluster approach. Okay. Exactly.
We won't do that today. I won't I
won't put pressure on you. So
we get this kinda alright. Here we go.
We got step by step guidance through the
filter. So when it says the filter of
kpt, that's just going through all of the
components that you kinda listed on those slides.
Right?
Exactly.
That will will explain how to install it.
It will explain how to do
delivery
with kptn, quality gates with kptn, and
automated operations
or let's call it self healing with kptn.
And we'll bring also all the
the tools that you will need. So in
this case, yeah, we'll ask you to install
Istio because that's what we are using for
the route
generation
and the traffic shifting between the blue green
versions.
So this is the this is why we
need this deal in this case.
Alright. So as this is recommending that I
run s two one five.
I'll just check what I actually have.
Okay. So should I install this version? Does
the version matter?
We I have not tried with the with
the the latest versions. We just had that
the previous versions did not work pretty well,
so we just decided to go for this
version.
This is the most stable version in
for our
demos here.
Alright. That's fine.
Why did that not work?
Oh, because I put the path after.
Let's just do this.
Much better. Okay. So we have a steel
control one six five.
We're just gonna run and install against
our cluster.
Default profile, the correct one. Yep.
The default. Yes. That's cool.
It's just one of those things that I've
been putting off for so long to play
with that I really am gonna have to
start experimenting with it eventually.
Actually, when when you're using kptn, you won't
see a lot of Istio because we will
be the kptn is generating
the the virtual services and all the traffic
routes that you will need
for for Istio,
the ingress, these kind of things. So we
won't see a lot of Istio. It's just
used behind the scenes.
But it's definitely a very, very interesting project.
Is that something that kpting could, you know,
more have a dependency on the service mesh
interface rather than STO, or is there stuff
on STO specifically that's needed for a captain
to work beyond to the service mesh interface?
We only
so if we are not use if we're
not doing continuous delivery with kptan, if we
are using, let's say, Argo CD for continuous
delivery and we are just using kptan for
the quality gate part and the automated remediation
part, then we won't need Istio.
It's when we are going for the full
installation of and we want to do continuous
delivery, we need Istio.
We were thinking about also moving to the
service mesh interface,
then also supporting Linkerd and other service meshes.
But it's just
it was never the right time to to
broaden up for this because what what we
see is that
more reusing already existing
CD tools like Argo CD, Argo Rollouts,
Spinnaker,
and trying to integrate with them and actually
providing integration with them
seems like the better approach right now.
Alright. Makes sense.
Alright.
So,
yeah, we've got installation complete. We hit next,
And
I'm curling
for a captain c l I.
Here we go.
Okay.
That was fast.
My connection's pretty good. Well, we know when
it wants to be, of course. There are
definitely days where it's not good, but today
it's been pretty good.
So we have the kpten CLI. Nice. Okay.
That that's pretty good.
So
yeah. And now with the kpten CLI, we
can install kpten in our Kubernetes cluster.
And
as said, for our installation
type, we are going for this use case,
continuous delivery.
If we don't decide for this use case,
then it will be a smaller installation of
kpten without the services
to to do the full continuous delivery, but
then we have to take care of doing
continuous delivery by ourselves. So we just go
for full installation here.
Okay. So you want me to change continuous
delivery to fill or as continuous delivery that
fill installation?
That's
so we just leave it like it is.
Yeah. Alright. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. That's
the, like, let's say, the the full installation
with the continuous delivery use case included,
which just ask us if everything
correct. Yeah.
I'm just gonna keep clicking buttons when things
are presented. If I do it if I'm
wrong, just feel free to to yell at
me. But so this is gonna
oh, so it's installing captive. So I could
have done this for the the helm chart
as well. I'm assuming the CLI is just
a wrapper around that, provides some values for
the use cases that are are selected. Is
that roughly right?
Yes. Yes. Exactly. We had it differently
that we had a really it like, a
a a job that was really executing
step by step the capital installation, but we
we thought it's best to move to Helm
chart since it also provides possibility
to install it via a Helm chart without
the installer. That's what we also see.
Sometimes it's not allowed to install any software
with an installer script,
but just with helm charts so that organizations
have full control and can take a look
what is actually installed. In this case, it's
basically applying the helm chart,
and we will see a couple of pods
spinning up in the captain namespace. So we
install everything in one namespace,
and that's the captain namespace.
If we if if you want, we can
we can try kubectl get pods minus end
captain. We will see
the what it's actually creating here. Yeah. We'll
see. That's basically
the
the core of captain.
Couple of different services that talk to each
other.
Okay. So we've got engine x for the
gateway.
We've got bridge. I don't know what that
is yet. We've got config, and we've got
an event broker. Is is that NAT, sir?
Are you using something else there for the
event broker?
It's actually yeah. It's NATs. So you can
also see the captain nets cluster
that's deployed. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Then we the
the the bridge is actually the captain's bridge
is the, let's say, the control center of
captain. That's it, our UI.
We will see the UI later.
The lighthouse is the one component that
is responsible for reaching out to all these
SLI providers and doing the evaluation.
Yeah. The shipyard is responsible for creating the
environments.
Is gatekeeper open policy agent
or something else? It's it's our own internal
gatekeeper. It's the the one component that decides
if one
version of a microservice is allowed to move
on to the next stage or not. It's
it's doing this decision making.
Right.
I'm not seeing any puns here for walking
the plank. So I think we need a
a new service for that, for maybe infecting
other apps.
Alright.
I like the nautical same. It's always amusing.
Okay.
So let's
let's see what's next.
So we have to
configure STO and kpten.
I guess I just trust this and run
it.
You can yeah. It's actually this one is
just downloading,
and the next one is then
we will just run-in the next command. So
we would can take we can also take
a look here. It's
what what it's doing is it will create
the ingress,
and
it will create also a a gateway,
and it will restart
our
re restart one service of of kpten that
it can fetch this configuration.
Alright.
K.
So we're just gonna
run it.
Parameters. Nope. Okay. Good.
Alright. Let's give that a second.
Alright. And then it tells you what it's
doing anyway. Right. Cool. Got it.
And now we need to configure our CLI
to speak to the control plane.
Exactly.
Verify this.
Okay. So we already see where your Kubernetes
cluster lives. So we can take a look
at the API endpoint.
And there is also the the bridge that
will be exposed here.
I will just warn you. So whenever we
are doing the we
yeah. That's the the API of kptn. It
can be controlled via the
the CLI
or via the API.
And, yeah, you can imagine that when Citrix
built integration with the Slack bot, they were
more using the API.
Today, we will be more using the CLI
since it's easier instead of writing all these
cloud events and then sending them to the
API.
Yeah.
And yeah. So with this, we already installed
kptn. We have access to the kptn API,
so we know it's up and running. And
we could also already take a look at
the kptn's bridge, but it will be empty
anyway. So we can go ahead and create
our first project, onboard offered services, and then
take a look at the bridge.
Okay. So we're gonna clone.
Okay. So it's just an example repository.
And then we're gonna take a look at
onboarding karts.
I should just
pop open.
Okay.
Nice.
So I oh, wait.
So I still have to create the project.
Okay. I've just cloned it and opened it,
but it's Yes. And here we can go
if you want, we can link it to
a public Git repository
in GitHub or GitLab or wherever you might
run you might wanna run it. So we
can also take a look at all the
different
projects and all the on everything that has
been created by kpten, or we can just
assume that everything's fine and we just trust
that the kptn repository
that is managed by kptn in its in
its in the cluster
is will be fine. So we can go
with the git upstream or we can also
link it afterwards. So right now, we can
also go with the installation without the Git
upstream, and we can do the link ups
the the Git upstream afterwards if we want.
So that's just that's open to you.
Alright. So
let's see.
So I I could just create a an
empty repository and then fill in those variables.
Is that Yeah. So we we could you
can even create an empty organization,
and
you can have it there. So you afterwards,
you can delete the whole organization if you
want. It they're also for free organizations.
Okay.
Let's call Rawkode
captain.
I own email address.
Oh
oh, alright.
Skip.
Okay. So I have
an organization.
There we go. Yes. And we just need
one project in this organization.
Yep. Yep. And that.
Since we are going to onboard let's call
it sock shop since we are going to
onboard a shopping cart.
I think for captain,
please make it sock shop without the dash
because in previous versions, we had issues with
the dash and just make sure everything's fine
here.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay. So then here, what we need is
just to expose these.
K. So let me just modify them here.
So is that my organization or my actual
username?
That's your actual username.
Then k. Yeah, we would need the
Rawkode.
Or you can just copy the
can you I'm not sure if it would
would work in this way.
Maybe we just need the,
the URL that gives that is given by
GitHub.
Oh, it's actually it's exactly this. Okay. Sorry.
Then it's is it?
Okay. I I always go for the HTTPS
version, so this is why I'm confused.
Alright.
Right. Yeah. Maybe we can go for the
HTTPS version. I think that is
actually the one that we
that we want.
I actually need a get token?
Yeah. And we might need this token, but
I'm not sure if we can share it
here on the screen or you would go
for a different display or monitor where where
you're going to set this. Yeah. I'm just
getting one over here.
So let me get token,
personal access.
Any specific
permissions it means?
Read write project will be just fine. So
I think that's the first two permissions.
K.
Let's see what happens then once that
done.
So what I'm gonna do is just move
this over here.
And that
and all the secrets on the stream is
always the fun bit. Okay. So
I can pull this back
and pull my terminal back.
Yeah. I I should have warned you warned
you earlier, but
I totally forgot.
Oh, yes. I need to export that variable.
So
get token.
See
what happens.
And
the
documentation
just wants me to run
this command
here.
Just didn't copy.
Alright. So we get.
So what's going on here? Do you wanna
fill this in a little bit?
So
what kpt will do is here, it will
start to create the project and it will
create different stages. And these stages will be
managed by branch.
So it is going to create the project
sock shop.
That also means
the folder in the git repository creating the
branches in the git repository, and it should
already be synced to your git upstream. So
it's always doing this
that it will sync it to a Git
upstream. So if you reload
it here, we can already see the shipyard
file,
and you will also see three different branches
for dev staging and production. So with this,
we have already created a, let's say, the
environment of a multistage pipeline,
dev staging production.
And, if we can take a look in
the shipyard file,
we will see
how this is configured.
So in our dev stage,
we do have a deployment strategy which is
direct, so no blue green deployments
for for our dev stage.
We just deploy directly into the dev stage,
and we execute some functional tests. That is
the instruction how this stage should be, should
be set up and is set up by
kptn. For staging,
we have a deployment strategy, which is a
blue green on the service level and the
test strategies performance tests. So the
test integrations,
they get the,
let's say, instructions to execute performance tests,
and an approval strategy is set to automatic
for for everything. That means
either or it doesn't really matter if the
quality gate gives us a warning or a
full pass,
we promote it automatically into this stage. For
production,
the approval strategy is a little bit different.
If it's a full pass, we we deploy
it automatically into production. If we get a
warning, we would have to click on or
approve it manually either by clicking in the
captain's bridge or doing this with the Slack
bot or with an API call. Just approving
this, you can have an integration with other
tools as well. And, we also have a
remediation strategy for production.
So that means if there's any issue,
any alert sent from,
let's say, the Prometheus alert manager in production,
kpt will trigger a remediation.
For other stages, kpt won't trigger remediation.
This is this is basically everything that we
have defined
in this, and this is how kpt will
behave in these different stages.
Alright. That makes sense.
Okay. So we have a a a question
as well, which we can tackle just now
before we move on. Is asking,
does captain expose any metrics that can be
consumed?
The kpten directly does not, right now expose
its own metrics, how the of the performance
of kpten, if if this is the questions.
Kpten,
can collect
different metrics from SLI providers.
And which metrics like a response
time or total amount of calls or what
whatever you you can think of, these are
just defined in the SLI file. So you
would just map it between the name of
the SLI and the prompt query, for example,
or if you're using other monitoring tools, the
name of the SLI and, let's say, an
API call how to to fetch this query.
Okay. Thank you.
So let me just make sure I understand
what's happened right now. So
we have this repository created.
I mean,
if I click on dev here,
we just got some metadata. So nothing's really
being deployed to our cluster yet.
Right?
Exactly. We just defined that there will there
is a project SOC shop, but we have
not onboarded the microservices yet. We can think
of, we have defined the the whole application
that we have a a container for this
application,
and a logical container, let's say. And now
we will onboard services.
So we could onboard a front end, a
database, a back end.
And what we will do is
the demo application comes with two microservices.
One is the database. It's not really a
microservice. It's a database, and the other one
is the microservice.
And we will then do different deployments with
with this demo application.
Okay. Let's jump back over to our tutorials.
So
we have
oh, that's alternatively. Okay. Yes. Okay. So if
you don't want to have this Git upstream,
if you just want to do it locally,
then it's totally fine. It's also working.
Okay. So now we can take a look
at the bridge. This one this one will
print an a token for the bridge since
it's just a demo environment. If you're fine
with the token to be exposed on the
stream, if you delete the installation afterwards, it's
totally fine. But just
Okay. Yeah. That's fine.
And then we're going to
render this.
What's that doing? Let's see. Echo,
get ingress. Alright. Okay.
So this is gonna print out a URL,
which we can click on this. Of course,
it went to the wrong tab.
Yeah. Just copy that. There we go.
And now I need our password here.
So let's see. And and go.
Yeah.
Alright. So this is the user interface.
I can select
application. I can see my three environments.
Not much going on just yet. Services and
okay. Some integrations.
Cool.
Let's
see what's next.
Now we have to onboard our first service.
Exactly.
And in the tutorial,
we have two services that we want to
onboard. The first one is the cart. It's
actually the application of the shopping cart.
And in the in step two,
what we also do directly here is that
we add test instructions
for, our different stages. So for dev, we
will test, we will add test instructions for
Chimida, which is just a functional test, basically
checking if the API is available,
of the cars microservice.
And for the performance test, it runs a
couple of thousand requests against the service. So
this is everything that we can see here,
is
creating the application,
and onboarding actually the Helm chart. So this
command will also upload the Helm chart that
lives in the carts
folder.
We'll upload this to the git repository.
Is
that a table, carts?
No.
That's actually correct. It's a it's a little
misleading
because it's the carts. It's a cart chart.
And it's a chart of the cart.
Alright. So let's onboard that then. Let's pop
over here after onboarding.
Okay. Yeah. Let's run that. Give
that a second.
And the cool thing here that you just
have to define your helm chart once, and
then you basically pass it on to captain.
And from this point, you don't have to
touch the helm chart. You can do most
of the things with, cloud events or with
the captain CLI,
and,
you don't have to, to maintain
it
they they will be managed in the captain
git repository,
and depending on the stage.
So what we've seen is for the staging
and the production environment, we have defined a
blue green deployment.
So there will be different
manifests Kubernetes manifests created for these different stages
because for blue green, we need virtual services
for Istio.
For direct deployments, we don't need this. We
can go with the standard Kubernetes
services.
So this is just how it's
how it's done.
Actually,
it should return
a little bit faster.
Maybe that's the
the git sync that it might take a
while, but,
yeah, we'll see.
So should we see anything
here?
Oh, yeah. It's had a push list a
minute ago. Okay.
So we can see that it's, yeah, it's
added all the chart stuff. Okay.
And
It's getting there.
Inject an STL into the thing.
I copy paste. It's a bit temperamental today.
Let's just try again.
What
does it mean by resource
here?
It means it will upload the basic check
dot JMX.
It's it's an instruction to
for a JMeter
execution,
and it will just add this resource to
the JMeter folder
for the service carts, so for the shopping
cart
in our dev stage.
And for staging, you've also just uploaded
a file. So if you go, for example,
yeah, in dev,
we will see in carts two folders,
one for helm and one for already.
And here, we just have the instructions which
tests to execute.
Is one service that is when you install
kpten with the continuous delivery
use case, g meter is installed with kpten
by default. You can, of course, remove it
afterwards,
but it's just one of those what we
call battery included services
since we see it's it's widely adopted that
organizations have g meter files and use JMeter
for their performance and load tests. And so
with this, you can just add the JMeter
file, and the JMeter service will then pick
up those files and will execute them.
We'll see this just in in in a
second.
So,
you know, if
I wanted to, could I
omit the captain at resource command and just
add the get add and push myself?
Would that still work, or is there gonna
be something missing from that?
You could actually
yeah. You can also do it with the
git add and git push.
That works
since kpten always
first takes a look at the remote branch,
syncs it to its internal git repository, and
then executes. So whenever there's new changes on
the remote branch,
it's
kptn will pick them up.
K. So now we're gonna onboard
our database.
Right?
Power safety.
For this,
we can also see it here as the
last parameter in the in in this line
that we are overriding here the deployment strategy.
So we have defined the deployment strategy
on the level of the project.
We defined for
it's in-depth, it's direct. In staging, it's blue
green, and in production,
it's also blue green.
For
the database,
we don't do blue green deployments in this
case, so we just go for
a direct deployment for the database.
We won't do a lot of deployments with
the database anyway, so it doesn't really
really matter.
Alright. Well, that finishes. Let's just tackle a
couple of questions we've received. So Bella has
asked, would kptim be suitable for deploying on
edge devices?
Yes.
So
it's if you have your
as I said, right now, kpten is doing
deployments on the same cluster where the kpten
control plane is also installed.
So I would not go right now for
edge devices here. But, with, the next version
of kpten, it's totally possible to do deployments
also to other clusters or to, to to
edge devices.
That's that's totally possible.
Yep.
Okay. I mean, I guess you could have,
like, depending on the edge setup. But if
those edge edge devices are all part of
Kubernetes cluster at a control plane centrally managed,
I mean, captain could also just run there
and still do deployment to those nodes even
though they're distributed, I would imagine. And you
also mentioned the captain runs on k c
s as a start of the stream, which
I guess may be a good fit for
those edge scenarios as well.
Okay. One more question.
Some pass is asking, is the ingress running
on the local host for the captain dashboard?
Ingress is running
on our cluster Kubernetes cluster is the same
one as captain.
I don't know. Have you provided a few
I don't know how to answer that just
now. I'm not sure if you do, Jorgen,
but maybe some path you could provide a
few extra details there.
Okay.
We've onboarded our cache DB. So now it's
telling me, hey, go look at the UI.
Let's do that.
Alright. We can see we have two services.
Not deployed yet, though.
Exactly. So
it's
everything that we have done until this point
is basically a one time setup. So we
have created the project. We've onboarded our services.
We've not yet deployed them, but they already
know which tests they have to execute once
we deploy them. They know if they
should be deployed in a blue green fashion
or if remediation should be executed for them.
So we have already provided all these instructions.
And in the next part, we now
deploy
the carts database
and the carts microservice.
So in the in the first part, we
deploy the the database.
And here, we can also see a little
bit of
the kptn
insights
and and details because we call it captain
sent event new artifact. That's a very
strong hint that kptn is event based. It's
not an operator living in a Kubernetes cluster
and and and doing things and looking for
changes on the Git repository,
but it's really an it's really event based.
So every time there is a new event,
captain will act upon this event.
And you send these events as a as
a as a cloud event to the captain
control plane. So is this something I would
use with Jenkins or GitHub actions? Every time
I have a successful build, I would maybe
send a captain event there.
Exactly. That's exactly what,
people that are using captain,
are doing.
Once you have a a container image,
then you trigger captain.
K. Let's just get both of these going
then.
Well, we've told that that the CartsDB service
has an image. So it's just gonna pull
it from the Docker Hub.
So that's just very synchronous right now with
the kpt and send event. Is there a
way I can just say send the event
and don't get me any feedback? Like, just,
you know, go and do it?
That's basically what what you will be doing
with the API.
The API will just respond
200 if the
the cloud event is okay.
This one is always opening up the the
WebSocket. Can also omit the WebSocket. It's I
think it's dash dash no
WebSocket or suppress WebSocket.
If you go to the kptn help,
then you you you will find it.
Press WebSocket. Okay.
Suppress WebSocket. Yeah. So
then it won't do the
the WebSocket communication.
And oh, it says unknown flag project. No.
This is a global flag.
Let me move that.
Oh, yeah.
I copy it wrong? No.
I think it looks good.
Maybe we can just put the suppressed WebSocket
at the very end.
Maybe Is this a COBRA application?
Yeah.
It's always weird.
Oh, no. Let's just remove it. Oh, artifact
is is is wrong. Our artifact, it says
here.
Always my fault. Always always is my fault.
There we go. Artifact fact.
User error. Okay. And that was very quick.
So I should set the event by suppressing
the WebSocket. I'm saying just go to wherever
you have to do in the background. So
Exactly. And but what you always get is
the captain context ID.
And with this captain context ID, you can
always query the events that belong to this
captain context. So in this case,
kpt would start the deployment. It will now
do the deployment in the Kubernetes cluster.
It will trigger the tests.
It will do the evaluation after the tests
have been finished, and it will decide if
should if it should be promoted to the
next stage or if we or if it
should stop.
So everything is done now
starting from here.
And in the Captain's Bridge, you can follow
the the sequence of events.
And it will just this demo application
is I think it's a spring boot application.
It's not
tweaked,
let's say, in any way, so it will
just take a while to to be deployed.
Here, we should already see actually the cards
to be.
Yes. So cards to be already says it's
Mongo four two two,
and we also have the configuration
for the first service. Yeah. It's not yet
finished with deployment, but that's not the problem
of the of of kpten that it's slow
with deployment. It's just that the demo application
or this carts application just takes a while
for
to come up and the for the first
readiness probe to be finished.
Awesome.
Okay. So has given us a little bit
of extra detail on their question. So what
they're saying is when we ran captain configure
bridge output
as does that command create a public load
balancer?
I think I know the answer to this,
so you can feel free to correct me
if I'm wrong.
But I I don't think it does. I
think it's just querying the IP addresses from
the services inside the clustered. When we installed
STL, it deployed the STL gateway, which then
requested a load balancer from the provider. So
that that was all set up with STO.
There is no ingress set up as far
as I'm I know
with that command. Is that right?
Yes. So the ingress was really part of
the
of of of the STO part.
Yeah. K. It was. Cool. And the configure
bridge, think, was just getting us a a
URL that we can use. So
Exactly. And if you're not familiar with the
NetIO,
it's just
a free service
where
you can put any IP address in their
format. Like, you can see here, if I
let me submit on that a little bit.
Really cool when you don't wanna have to
deal with DNS records at all, and and
it just maps back to the IP address,
which is part of the actual domain name.
A really cool service.
Okay. So
let's see what's coming up next. This is
fifty eight minutes remaining. There must be quite
a lot in this tutorial.
Yeah. It is. It is. But actually, it's
just a a wild guess of this fifty
eight minutes, so we we can always be
a little bit faster.
But let's see if the it's already
in stock shop dev cards is still
We have something pending. So let's just take
a look at that and see if we've
had any sort of challenge.
Insufficient CPU.
Okay.
We got six notes. I mean, that
it should be alright. I
think that's just a problem that the demo
application, we have not tweaked the
the resource request. So maybe it's just looking
for a little bit too much.
Alright. Let's take a look at our resources.
Okay. Let's just
that's the limit, and then this is the
request.
If I modify that resource.
Yeah. Actually, I think easiest is that we
modify this in the public repository
that we that we did the
that we set up in the beginning.
Ah, right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Okay. So
back and back Because that will be synced
anyway,
so we should be able to see this.
But it will give us a hard time
because the Helm chart
okay. He here here comes the the thing.
The Helm chart is now you have it
in-depth in staging and in production. So we
wouldn't change
it three times
because
kpten is taking this helm chart and putting
it for each stage,
replicating this helm chart so you can have
it basically managed by each stage. So we
can try to tweak it here a bit
and go down with the
Alright. I mean, we can just remove it.
Right? We can just say we don't really
care.
Yep.
Where is the save button?
I know I should enter a better commit
message,
oh, well.
So what what happens when I do that?
Does anything happen?
Right now, nothing happens because we have not
yet sent an event to captain.
Yeah. So we've just changed the deployment file,
and what we should do is to send
the new event to captain to to do
the deployment. So, basically, the same command that
we had earlier. And we trigger a new
deployment, and captain will fetch this
will fetch this again.
K. Let's give that a minute, I guess.
And you're saying I should modify this in
staging and production as well?
Yes. But can you take a look in
the helm
there is also a there's a helm and
a helm generate or a cards and a
cards generated folder.
And here, we actually have to take a
look in the carts generated
since
these
the carts is the original one that we
onboarded,
and the carts generated is the one where
we also have the Istio
resources
that have been created by kpten.
I
I don't see anything.
And
in the dev stage
or in the dev branch
the staging, sorry, in the staging branch
Yep. We should see them.
No. Nothing. Okay. Then
then we have to take a look in
the carts. Yeah. Then maybe it's not in
a generated. Then I'm totally wrong.
So for dev, we already fixed it. That's
fine. We have to take a look in
the
Doesn't seem to be
doing anything. Okay. So let me try and
understand what's going on here. Is there a
way for me
can I subscribe
to the captain event? Can I see what
events have been happening? Can I how would
I debug this situation?
We can take a look in the captain's
bridge what is going on.
So we would see that there is a
new service sent or a new deployment
sent
in-depth.
Oh, did did did I send it to
the right
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's no environment there. So
that that command is okay, isn't it?
Yeah. That's that's fine. We can just remove
the the suppressed WebSocket so we can also
see the logging output because that's actually what
we are
we don't see right now.
But
we'll see starting updating
the chart cards of the stage dev.
There we go. And here we go. Has
no deployed releases. Okay. It failed in the
first time, so the Helm release is actually
not
working. So
now it's basically in the undefined state with
Helm. That's the I've had this so many
times with Helm where the first release fails
and then you get stuck in this limbo
land where you need to actually remove the
the old release.
So
if I I mean, will my standard Helm
tooling work here?
Oh.
Yeah. It it should work actually because helm
should also point to the same cluster.
And There we go. Okay. So Yeah. We
can do
a shop. It's SOC shop minus dev. This
is how the
Delete
and the release name.
That's no. That's d p.
The
I don't see it.
The event probably had it. Didn't say yeah.
Okay.
This one.
There we go. Okay. So we could we
should be able to to trigger that new
artifact again, and they should start from a
clean slate,
maybe? Yeah. But is there any chance that
we can,
like, bump the size of the cluster a
little bit? Because it will do the same
in
staging
and in production. But in staging and production,
we will do a blue green deployment. So
we have two versions of cards running.
So we might run out of space also
in staging and production because, like, we are
adding five
more containers
to the show.
Yep. No problem. Okay.
Go.
Alright. I've increased that size. There's a new
node pill being added now, which should give
us five more nodes.
So
let's see where status of that is.
Did I do that right?
And I think that gives me the the
chance to to rethink about our demo application
since it's a little bit too big for
very, very small shopping cart, and it takes,
just too much resources.
It's,
yeah, it's just that we we're going for
a database plus
a small a small UI and a little
bit of yeah. It's just a small microservice.
Maybe we should go with two small microservices
that talk to each other and are very,
very small, maybe just pinging each other, and
then we can also showcase
the capabilities.
Alright. Let's just see how far along that
is. It shouldn't take too long.
Let's see.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
I can see if you're adding my new
note pillow. Okay. I'm just gonna increase the
size of that. So I may lose
the API server for a few minutes, but
we can deal with that.
The joys of a livestream. Right? K.
Let's see.
Exactly. Yeah. Maybe we have more questions coming
in that we can also do a couple
of questions.
Let's see.
Happy now.
Yeah. Okay. And that should be spinning up
now. So let's see what happens. We'll give
that a second. Okay.
We do have one question just now we
can tackle, and then we'll cover a few
other things. So Bella asked, does the user
have to manually update STO to keep up
with their releases?
Yes. So Istio is not managed by kpten.
It's just for
blue green deployments right now. It's it's needed
by kpten, but it's not managed. So you
would just install it by yourself and
take care of the latest versions of Istio.
Maybe in this context, I can add that
upgrading
kpten is
usually done with the kpten CLI.
So we release
a new kpten version every
four to six weeks
approximately.
And
there you can usually, it's just a kptan
upgrade,
and it will just upgrade your kptan installation
and move all the the services
to its latest version. If there are new
versions of other depending services
released, then you would just have to take
care of of this yourself.
Cool. Thank you. Alright. Can I trigger
caption send event again, and we should see
that work this time? I won't suppress the
WebSocket. Let's follow along and see what happens.
Let's try.
So I guess that also explains the
weird situation then because you were expecting
this here to see the generated
YAML,
which I'm assuming isn't there maybe just because
that release wasn't successful the first time.
Is that right? Yes. Yep. There are a
couple of things going on. The Helm chart
will be generated,
and the Helm chart will be applied.
And the CLI will wait for the Helm
chart applied to for the Helm upgrade. Actually,
I think it's a command to be finished.
So in this case, it takes a while
since
just the the start of the container takes
a couple of seconds. So, normally,
it's this command if you have
I have a very small Go application that
I'm using sometimes. It's called the potato head.
It's a CNCF demo project.
And with the potato head, this command finishes
within, let's say, five seconds because it's very
small. It's start up it like, the start
up is really fast.
With the shopping cart, the start up is
a little bit longer
and and slower. So, also, this command just
waits for the first successful deployment in the
first stage.
So it won't wait until it's deployed into
production, but it will just give you the
feedback if it could be deployed in the
first stage. So it finished upgrading the chart.
That should be fine. And,
yeah, now it's writing the generated ones, and
now it's all good. There we go. There
we go. Finally.
Alright. So that what what it turns out
then is my wild idea of a suppressed
the WebSocket. We actually managed to tighten that
rate. I did it on the request that
failed. So go me. Thanks.
Alright. Let's go back to our tutorial.
So we
have done both of those,
and we should be able to verify all
this now. So let's try that one more
time.
Here we go. That looks much better. So
we got the staging. And now we can
also see it's, it's starting up already in
staging.
There is also difference,
when we take a look at the the
pods and the containers that are running in
the pods.
For,
dev, there is only one container running. For
staging and production, there will be two containers
because we will also have the Istio sidecar.
But for dev, we decided not to go
for
blue green deployment. So there is no need
to inject the Istio sidecar because we we
don't need this traffic shifting between blue and
green versions, and we're only going for this
in staging and in production.
We if we take a look in the
Captain's Bridge,
there should already be
the link to the service
available so we can also take a look
at the UI of this very beautiful
shopping cart.
Actually
yeah. It's
deaf. Yeah. Here we go. And that's our
shopping cart. Yeah. So it took a it
took a while to see this very nice
UI.
Cool.
So I'm just curious then.
If I come in here, take a look
at this.
The this one
get the change that I made in dev.
Right? This is something I would have to
manually update here.
Let's even get away with with those extra
notes. Okay.
So that's cool. Nice. So
it's we've already looked at that. I'm happy
with that. We
go to next. Now it wants to generate
some traffic.
Yep.
Do we want to do that or will
we We we can also skip this part
as we
I think what's really important to
where we
sorry. I think did I just lose you
for a second?
Oh, no. Okay.
So I think what what what will be
interesting to take a look at is how
we can connect kpten to Prometheus
and also run a quality gate evaluation with
data from Prometheus maybe.
I think we still have a couple of
more minutes left in the stream. Or, David,
how long is the stream scheduled for another
couple of minutes?
I
mean, it's scheduled for another fifteen minutes. If
you wanna go over that, I'm fine. As
long as you've got the time, we can
we can go until we get the Prometheus
stuff done.
Yeah. I I think if we just execute
the installation of Prometheus
and do the configuration,
should be quite fast, and we will get
the data.
Yeah. But now that you've said that, something
random is gonna happen. Right?
So we're deploying Prometheus.
We are gonna configure captain.
Okay. We're just telling that that Prometheus
yeah. Captain configure a module from Prometheus. So
this is a command that
you wanna tell me what that does?
Yeah. It it it also says here. So
what it does is it will set up
Prometheus,
and it will also, configure Prometheus in a
way that it will, generate the scrape jobs
for cards in dev staging production,
that we can use the data afterwards.
And if we would have set up already
the SLO files, the Qualitygate files, that it
would already set up the alert manager rules.
So right now, we have not added the
SLO files, so there is no alerting yet
since we have not defined the QualityGate yet,
but this will be the next part.
Okay. Got it. Yeah.
So this is using my local shipyard, right,
to kind of pieces together. When I run
this captain
configure monitor, it's looking in this the shipyard
fail here? Or no. It's sending the event
to the control plane. It's sending the event
to the control plane. It's taking a shipyard
file from the git repository.
Got it. Okay. That makes sense.
We don't need to browse to Prometheus. So
Yeah. We can go for the next.
And
here, sometimes I need a little bit of
explanation because it's the Prometheus service. That's the
one responsible for configuring Prometheus.
If you don't want to configure Prometheus with
kpten, then you just need the Prometheus SLI
service, service level indicators.
In our case, we want to do both,
so we have the Prometheus service and the
Prometheus SLI service. So this service we also
need, it's a service that we also deploy
into our
kpten namespace,
and it it's just responsible for querying Prometheus
and delivering the data from Prometheus to kptn.
And with that, we already set up Prometheus
and the integration.
And now we need the quality gate,
and the quality gate is our SLO file.
It's written here, and we can just use
it as it is.
And it will check basically for the
let's say
I think it's for the response time. We
were just checking for the response time of
phone service.
Okay. Yeah. So it's an an average across
response time, p 95.
Okay. And it's got some criteria. Excellent.
Exactly.
Okay.
So I can do this just from the
bridge. Right?
Yes. So we can take a look if
it's already deployed in
staging or in production.
Both service. Oh,
environment staging.
Cart.
It's here. That looks good.
I think in production, I have not seen
it yet.
Its cards is not yet deployed in production.
B b is there. Not yet there. Maybe
we can take a look in the bridge.
Normally, the bridge gives us
if we go to
on the left side, if we go to
services,
then we can take a look directly on
the service on the carts.
And if we click on the last configuration
changed,
we can see we the configuration changes is
usually the part
Oh, it's
trying to already fetch the SLIs.
Actually,
it's trying to fetch the SLIs.
And at the same time, we just deployed
Prometheus. So I think
there is a kind of a race condition
here because
this part would be skipped if Prometheus is
not installed. So normally, you install you can
do it without monitoring, and then it will
just just be skipped.
This time, we just we deployed Prometheus, but
we have not added already the the other
parts. So what we can do is we
can just do another
deployment
or trigger a new deployment of carts to
just rerun the the whole thing
with the same version,
and it will it will then fetch the
data.
Okay. So I just wanna make sure I
understood that correctly. So our production approval strategy
has some sort of performance monitoring before it
does an automatic rule out, and it just
managed to capture Prometheus existing and time for
it to try and check that the performance
was adequate,
roughly? Yes. So it's working in this way
that
with this command, we are deploying cards in
the dev
namespace.
Then,
kpten will trigger the tests. We have added
a JMeta file. This will be triggered.
Afterwards,
there will be an evaluation based on the
SLO file. We have not added the SLO
file for our dev environment.
We only added it for staging. So in
dev, it will just skip the quality evaluation.
For staging, it will deploy. It will trigger
the tests. We have added the load GMX
file, so we will add some performance tests
or, like, execute a couple of thousand requests
against this shopping cart,
and then it will do the evaluation. We
have defined the SLO file,
and we have defined the Prometheus SLI
provider.
So
this will actually query Prometheus
for the data of the testing
time
and then come back with the data, provide
this to kpten. Kpten will do the evaluation
based on the SLO file and then come
up with a total score. That is actually
everything that's going on in the background when
you just send this one command, kptn. And
I think at the beginning, mentioned that,
kptn access this control plane and the orchestrator
of these tools. So it connects a chain
meter, Prometheus.
Later on, it can connect
Unleash or Ansem Tower to trigger remediation actions.
So there's a lot of things that are
sent
that will receive events or send events.
So this
this is what we
this is what what what's going on here
in the background. Yeah. We can see
in this case, there is not a lot
of evaluation because we don't have the SLO
file. But if we add an SLO file
to to our dev state, dev environment,
they would would see it.
Actually, right now, it's quite fast.
The gatekeeper already decided that since we got
the let's say,
if there is no SLO file, kpt will
treat it as
as a,
let's say, a a past evaluation.
So it moved on, decided to promote
it to the next stage. For staging, we
have automated
deployment
activated,
so it already
started to deploy it in staging. And maybe
we already see that tests are executed in
staging.
But, yeah, we just need to to wait
a couple of seconds or minutes for the
the test to be finished.
Right. Okay. Okay. Gotcha. Yeah. So so so
we can see it here. Deployment finished, then
kpt was triggering the tests.
Kpt was also doing
the
was fetching then the SLIs,
evaluating the SLOs, and then deciding if to
promote it or not. So this is this
is how how it's going.
Alright. Nice. I like it.
So that's just gonna take another minute. Why
don't we tackle another quick question?
So the question is,
is the captain CLI using its own service
account and tokens when talking to the control
plane? I'm assuming
it may be just just using my cube
context. I'm not sure.
What
Yeah. We are
using our own service account. In the beginning,
we were just using the default service account,
but
that's
this was, I think, changed with
two versions ago, three versions ago. We changed,
and now we're using the captain service account.
So you have a little bit more
flexibility and control what captain is actually allowed
to do.
Alright. Nice.
Okay. So should I refresh this? It looks
like it's rolled out to dev and staging,
but I don't think we've had a production
deployed. It's still maybe we can take a
look in staging
if it's if the deployment has already finished.
Then if the deployment is already finished, then
we know that the tests are also executed
in the background.
Oh, we've had a CPU thing again.
Okay.
I'm assuming Okay. So we are we are
hitting another CPU limit.
Yeah. It's just the
I think the problem that we
Sorry. Let's just remove it, and then I'll
check it at another event, and we'll see
if we can get that to run through
a time.
So we can just say
in the CPU.
I'll just commit that to prod before doing
the new artifact as well.
Edit.
Yeah. This cluster has a lot of nodes,
but it's relatively small hardware.
I should have
and normally over provision out testing as well.
Like a billion course, but today I was
a bit more sensible.
So I'm gonna trigger this new event based
on those changes inside of the repository. So
yeah. Let's see what happens. I'm curious. So
would you say the bridge is the best
way to follow along a progressive rule out
of this application? Would you use the CLI?
I mean, what's your what's your preference as
someone that uses SDN, DOT?
I think the the bridge gives most details
because if for example, if we can take
a look in,
let's say, in the bridge
on
let's go for a previous run maybe, that
way we can see a little bit more,
and let's probably go for
some
okay. Maybe we don't see a lot of
data. Maybe go for an event
of
yeah. Anyway, go for go for any event.
On the very right hand side, there is
this computer icon
or laptop icon.
And here, it gives you the full cloud
event that was sent to kptn.
And
if you have a quality evaluation or a
SLI retrieval,
then these cloud events, they get a lot
of information. So usually, you have all this
information. You have also, if there is an
error message,
you should be able to see it there
if the SLI provider sends it. So
since
the
the reason that we are running out of
CPU is happening after the Helm upgrade,
we we don't see this exactly
because that would mean that we send another
event after we do the Helm upgrade.
But if there are, for example, if there
are any tests that are failing or if
there are some
service level indicators fetching, then we should be
able to see this we we should see
all this data here. Probably,
if we close this window and go to
the
test finished in our dev,
maybe in the previous run at 03:20,
there is a test finished event
on the in the dev stage. So it's
a little bit
on the top.
And maybe we can see here
yeah. It just says that it's coming from
the chain media service.
And, yeah, it doesn't bring a lot of
a lot of information. We just know that
the chain meter service sends a pass off
the tests. It just executed one test.
What we will see is
more in the in in staging. We have
added more tests, we should be able to
see this in staging.
Okay. So staging rollout is just about completed.
Looks like it's just waiting for the STL
sidecar maybe.
Well, you know, one container pending here. Yeah.
Well, it should pop up. Second.
I'm so impatient. I should just try to
watch.
That's
good. So one is coming up, and the
other one is, being terminated since we we
don't need it anymore.
That also means
that,
now the
tests
we have not made it yet to production
because the quality gate in staging never
was
not successful yet. So in in this case,
we could not we we cannot ship anything
to production as long as it's not validated
in staging.
Okay. So what we'll see is
the deployment finished.
And after the deployment is finished, right now,
the Chimida tests are being executed.
There is one improvement coming in the bridge
that we will indicate also that now tests
are being executed.
It's a little bit missing here, this information,
because we just see the deployment is finished,
and it needs some background,
in in kpten that we know, okay.
Every time the deployment is finished, captain will
trigger the tests. This information, unfortunately, is missing
in the bridge.
Yeah. We somehow missed to to also put
this information in the bridge, but we are
working on this to improve it.
Okay. So we just need to wait for
those tests. So does that take long?
Usually, about two minutes.
About two minutes. Couple of yeah. And then
I will just reach
out
to to move a couple of things.
Oh, have you got another call scheduled there?
Yeah. I think I can move it. So
I'm I'm I'm really excited here to to
get this into production.
You know, that that that's all we want
with kpt in the shipping applications to production
without breaking anything, and we are we are
good in breaking here. So
No. This this is this is look at
this. It's it's starting to click with me
now. I can see and I'm starting to
understand this UI kinda threw me at first.
But what, you know, what we can see
is the this config changed event here, and
then we're actually
it just I don't know how I missed
it, but we have the first event here
and then this is okay for development environment.
We're gonna do deploy. We're gonna run our
tests. You know, we get their SLI stuff
going on here. It does some evaluation and
you can actually see it move on to
staging. Like, I can actually start to see
how all this flows together now. It's starting
to make much more sense to me. In
fact, there we go. There's our production now.
Events kicking off. So
and I've had the light bulb moment. I
now understand what's going on.
This means if I pop over here okay.
So
we could see yeah. And the evaluation,
what what did it say? Could we did
we get a good score in the evaluation?
That's pretty,
pretty good. So we got,
basically
pass
with
90%,
which is no. Actually, with a %. So
what what we've done here is or what
kpten has done is it was triggering the
tests.
The tests have been finished. It was reaching
out to to
to query the data for the exact testing
time frame, and now we can see
that the response time is is meeting our
requirements. So that's that's pretty cool. And now
we're moving on to production.
And in production, it's doing the same the
same game
with
deploying,
trying to execute tests.
Actually, in production, we have not defined any
tests. Usually, it's our end users doing testing,
let's call it, for us in production.
But,
yeah, this is what we'll see. And with
a blue green deployment, we have prepared
a second version of this microservice,
which is a very slow version that will
break
the quality gate and that will not be
allowed to move on from staging to production.
I can already spoil this a little bit
because the tests are
yeah. I'm spoiling because the tests will be
running for a couple of more minutes since
we are sending the same amount of requests.
I think it's 5,000 or 10,000 requests against
the service. And instead of five instead of
two minutes, they will take about eight minutes.
And I'm not sure if we want to
wait these eight minutes to see this evaluation.
It will be red, and we'll be indicating
that the response time for the ninety fifth
percentile is not within the boundaries that we
defined. So this is this is what we
will see.
Okay.
So does
that does that change, and I mean, that
we have this deployed everywhere? I mean, if
I run get pods in production,
that's it. Oh, no. This is
so what's this primary
pod that's running? Is this more tests?
No. That's actually
since we're doing this blue green deployment, we
are spinning up the first version, and we
are spinning up also another version. So we
prepare the blue green, the traffic shift already.
This
time, it's the first deployment,
So we are bringing up two times the
same version, so we cannot really roll back
because there is no previous version. But if
we do more of those blue green deployments,
if we send the captain if we send
the shopping cart in version 11 dot three,
eleven dot or dot two, dot three
that are already prepared, then we can see
the primary is the one that's receiving the
traffic, and the other one is the one
that will go away. So in staging,
there is there are only there's only one
left, and in production, there are right now
two.
But if after some evaluation p
period,
if there is no rollback indicated,
then the other one will just be removed
from kpten.
Okay. I understand. Nice.
So is that my full rollout of karts
finished? In this case, yep. We are finished.
We it would have been possible to just
bring
cards on the on the on the browser
and
and take a look when there is the
traffic switch actually from one version to the
other.
We are doing the blue green deployments with
with Istio. So that means we are deploying
the new version. Once it's ready, we are
moving the traffic to this new version. And
we are if we're going back, then we
are first moving the traffic to the previous
version and removing this. So there's no downtime
or anything.
That's actually what we already know from Kubernetes,
but it's also in this this way we're
using
we are basically implementing a little bit by
ourselves,
but we made sure that there is no
downtime from switching from one version to the
other.
Alright. Cool.
Is there anything else you'd like to show
just now?
Pardon? Is there anything else you want to
go over?
So what what we've seen right now is
blue green deployment, the multistage
deployment with kpten,
with helm,
with using CloudEvents, with having Istio, with having
Prometheus. So I think we have installed a
lot and had a lot of technology.
Although the parts
that once set up,
it's basically just the kptn CLI that you
need with the kptn send event,
new artifact to trigger a new deployment, or
configure your monitoring
to to set this all up.
As said,
it just takes a while for the the
second version to run all its tests, but
we have also added the Chimida tests. I'm
I'm happy to to stay and then move
through all the other parts of the tutorial.
But,
yeah, if you want to wrap up here,
that's also totally fine. And maybe we can
do a follow-up and taking a look maybe
on the
auto remediation parts of kpten later on because
this is
basically, once we have things up and running
in production,
it's another use case of kptn to trigger
remediation actions and to evaluate these remediation actions.
Okay.
Okay. So let's let's
I have no idea. So let's just say
what we wanna do. I what I wanna
what I wanna be careful with is I
I I don't want to
rush anything that we show so that people
don't get a good understanding of it. But
at the same time, I'm I'm happy to
make sure that we, you know, we finish
off what we started now. So we can
definitely schedule something else and we can cover
more of the captain features.
You're saying if we deploy the slow one,
what that's gonna do is show us that
the tests fail on the staging phase, which
will block the deployment to production. So why
don't we trigger that now?
We'll see if anyone has any questions, and
we can do a little bit of a
summary while we wait for that to happen.
And then we can
schedule a follow-up, and we can dive even
deeper into anything that we haven't covered in
particular field.
Sounds good. Yeah. Let's let's deploy the slow
version
because it it will be quite nice to
see what what is going to happen.
That kpt will deploy it first, will trigger
the tests, then come back with,
like, the rollback
Yeah. Of this version. So that's what typically
happen in my CI system.
I said, hey. We have a new artifact.
We just built this new release. We tagged
it with 0112.
We send the event to captain.
What's happening here is that because captain has
an event driven system, it detects this change.
So let's yep. There we go. We can
we can see here.
And that's now gonna start to prepare the
deployment
to our development environment. And I just wanna
make sure we tile this together. If anyone
has questions, please drop them in the chat
and we'll we'll tackle that.
But if we come over to here
oops. Let's
go back to
the directories.
That's right. There we go.
This
this is like the entry point. This is
this describes all of our environments, the ship
shipyard.yaml.
And I just wanna make sure we we
cover this again. So we have a development
environment which has a deployment strategy of direct
and a test strategy of functional. So what
that means is
the deployment strategy will always deploy whenever there's
a new artifact. And the testing strategy means
it's gonna run the functional tests. And if
they pass,
it won't roll back the deployment.
Is my understanding of that correct?
Yes.
Okay.
So if my functional tests failed when I
built that new artifact, it would revert the
deployment back to the last working version.
And I get it wrong. Just interject.
In in this case, no. So if you
do a direct deployment, it won't roll back
anything.
What it will do is it will block
it from
from move on to the next stages, obviously.
So if, the functional tests fail or if
some
quality gate may be, responding on the or
checking the response time or the throughput or
the number of outgoing service calls or whatever.
If there is a quality gate that fails,
it will block it to move to the
next stage.
With a direct deployment, it will run rollback
is only supported in the in blue green
right now. Alright. Okay. Thank you. That makes
much more sense.
Then we have our staging environment. And this
time, we have an approval strategy of both
automatic on a pass and automatic on a
warning. So regardless,
it's gonna do its best. As long as
the test pass is gonna promote that
to the next stage.
And our testing strategy here isn't functional, but
performance.
Now
are these test strategies is this related to
the GMX configurations that we applied earlier?
Yes.
It's it's related also to the Chimera service.
So it's basically an indicator which kind of
test to execute.
The Chimera service, they also have a configuration
file, but it's not needed. There is no
additional configuration file needed. So we only added
the g m x file,
which was the basically already the test instructions.
The you can always add a little bit
more configuration
to configure the number of users and and
and concurrent users and number of requests to
be sent.
But the test strategy already indicates
which test
to execute. If it's just a functional test
that are usually a little bit faster or
performance test that hit more load. Yeah. Okay.
So these deployment strategy values, this this seem
kinda special. So we got direct. We got
blue green service. Is there like a Canadian?
Are there any other deployment strategies that we
haven't really looked at?
Canary is not yet supported.
Everything is prepared in the background. So with
Istio, it will be very easy to shift
the traffic not only from 100%
to 0%,
but doing, 100%,
then eighty twenty, 70 30, 50 50, whatever
you want to do. It's not yet implemented,
but this is something that's also coming in
the next stages.
It's interesting also that we have not received
or it's not the most common
thing that
that or not the most common request that
we get that we have to implement
Canary.
It's more the multi cluster support, actually, that
we already had in the stream that people
were asking. Yeah. Yeah. I can imagine why.
Okay.
And then the last part of our shipyard
demo, we define our production environment, has a
slightly different approval strategy of automatic slash manual
and then the remediation.
So
one of the things we've had at the
start, which was really subtle, but I think
it's also important, is that
I'm not gonna I better cut find the
commander. But when we onboard
it,
what did we all did we override
the
deployment strategy on one of these? Yeah. We
did here. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yep.
So for individual services, I can actually say,
you know, I I don't want a blue
green deployment of this. Like, I guess the
database is a really good example and probably
why it's included in this tutorial. You you
don't want to run two different versions of
them at the same time. You may just
want to go ahead and pay the bill
and get that running as fast as possible.
So
is that reflected in the get repository somewhere?
If I take a look
something?
Mhmm.
So if I go to
oh, that there won't exist.
And
put it dev.
There we go. And take a look at
CarsDB
Is it metadata?
No. It's actually the way we will that
kptn
stores in the Helm chart. So kptn won't
create
this virtual services for Istio if we don't
need a blue green deployment.
This is how we can see if it's
a blue green deployment or not.
There is no in the metadata file, you
won't really see it.
We are planning to also include this when
you're doing a kpt and get services or
kpt and get projects in the CLI that
we're also including everything that's
that's really
running in the cluster that we provide all
this information directly with the CLI or with
the API.
With by the API, you can already query
all the events that are stored and running
through kptn and also stored in kptn.
With the CLI,
it's
we we have a couple of convenience functions
that you can, like, kptn get projects, and
it already lists the projects
in a human readable way instead of giving
you the whole cloud event with all the
projects. So
yeah.
Cool.
Alright. So it's getting there. It's all coming
together now.
Let's see what's going on over here then.
So our dev environment, the test finish, we
only run functional. We don't run performance, which
is why we're getting a green evaluation.
This is now being promoted to staging,
and
it's not run test yet. So that's running
our performance tests now against
this red version here.
Exactly. So we know it's already deployed,
the red version. Yep. And we know that
there are the tests running. As said, I
would assume they still take a couple of
minutes. So normally, it's around
five to ten minutes. Normally, it's, eight minutes.
So in a couple of minutes, we should
see
if the tests have been finished successfully.
So that's also one of the
of of the the nice parts of this
integration that the chain meter service is
also indicating if the tests have been finished
successfully.
So it might happen that the tests are
breaking,
and we don't even get,
let's say, a successful test result from Chainmeter
because maybe the service is not available, maybe
the service was crashing.
And this is also taken into consideration of
kpten,
not only the SLO file. So if the
Chimera file or NeoLoad
sorry. If the Chimera tests or the NeoLoad
tests or whatever
test integration you're using. If this is failing,
then kpten will get this information and will
also
mark the quality gate evaluation as failed since
it could not even execute the tests.
If the tests have been executed successfully,
then kpt will go ahead and evaluate the
quality gate. And our quality gate is very,
very small.
We only have the response time in the
ninety fifth percentile. You can add more and
more s l SLIs. So we have seen
quality gates with
50 SLIs that are combined together, the total
score is generated.
And they range from number of outgoing service
calls to memory consumption, CPU saturation, response time
throughput, all these different metrics,
they are used.
And you just define them once in the
SLO file.
And, in the SLO file, we've that we've
seen also earlier,
it doesn't say which service it belongs to.
So if you have an SLO file that
is like your
standard configuration
of your quality
objectives,
then you can reuse it for all of
your microservices.
And reusing
is is easy in this way since
you you can define absolute thresholds,
but you can also define relative ones.
And I always like to have a combination
of both that I say, okay.
It's the error rate has to stay lower
than 5%,
but it's also not allowed to increase more
than 25%
to the previous bills. So an increase of
the error rate by 25%
is, like, rather frustrating,
let's say.
But
so I can combine the relative and the
absolute value
same for for for all the other metrics.
And in this way,
I think it's it's
it's very easy to reuse it also for
other services since they they don't have the
name of the microservice or the the the
stage in the SLO file itself. It's just
how you edit them to to kpten via
the CLI or via the API.
Alright. Nice.
So this test has been running for
seven minutes. So we're expecting this to come
back and crash and burn very, very, very
soon. Right?
Yeah. Exactly.
The next event should be this
SLI retrieval. So and the SLI retrieval, as
we know from Prometheus,
it's it's very fast. Usually, you get this
data
close to real time from Prometheus. So
other
solutions, they take a little bit more time
to digest and to to operate on this
data. But if we ask Prometheus for for
data, we get it
we we retrieve it pretty fast, and then
we should see the slide retrieval, SLI retrieval
done, and the evaluation of the quality gate
pretty soon.
And we should also see then
the action that is
is taken by kptn upon this quality kit
evaluation. So if kptn allows you to promote
promote it to the next stage or if
it will be rolled back to the previous
version,
and we remember that the previous version was
the green version. So we will see what
happens.
And can I just I I guess if
I pull up the pods in the staging
namespace, will that show me the tests?
You won't see the tests here because they
are executed by the g meter service that
is running anyway. Right. Right. Right. Okay. In
in previous versions of Captain, we built upon
k native
to to allow scaling down to zero for
a couple of different services of kpten and
only react when there is a new events
coming in.
But, actually, Knative was
the the memory footprint
of Knative was already quite
quite demanding, so we decided to remove Knative
and just go for Kubernetes and and allow
all the services to just keep running.
Right. We have our failure.
That's actually what we wanted. Yeah. That's good.
Yes. So it says here that
our SLA retrieval started. It's done. We do
our evaluation.
We can see that we have quite a
large amount of red here, and we can
see the result was a fail, which means
that this change will not be propagated to
production, which is what we want.
Which is pretty cool. Maybe we can take
a look if it actually did the rollback.
There is the service in the deployment finished
event. We should see the the blue arrow
that we can open up the microservice, and
we can take a look, and it's rolled
back to green. Nice.
There we go.
We made it. Awesome. Very, very cool. I
like that.
We got there. Alright. Nice. Yeah. We we
we did it. We did it. Awesome.
Yeah. There's
there's just so much going on there, but
I think the flexibility
and the way that we can encode essentially,
which is, you know, actually, play books to
a certain degree of how we want our
applications to handle failures. How we wanna build
test them across environments and and have captain
orchestrate all of that for us is a
really, really cool thing.
Call me pretty much impressed with what we've
seen here today.
And based on what
we have in this tutorial, you know
let me pull that back up again. It's
my stupid testing. We started forty minutes worth
of other things we could be looking at
as part of the filter. So maybe if
you could just take, you know, a minute
or, in fact, maybe we should just reschedule
something and not do that. Yeah. Let's do
that.
I think we've covered so much today. Is
there any final thoughts you wanna leave us
with? And we'll come back to this another
day.
I
think it was a very amazing journey that
we actually we did a little bit of
debugging already, and we took a look at
the the DevOps
sorry, the the the GitOps
the GitOps approach of kpten.
I think that was very fascinating to also
also for me to see this
how how fast we we've done these changes
of the small hiccups in the helm charts.
And, yeah, it was really a pleasure to
to walk through kpten here with you and
also seeing this from the from the other
perspective.
Not normally, I I'm sitting on the keyboard
doing all this.
Awesome. Well, thank you for Sorry, Nico.
So so I I I would be happy
to to join you again and to take
a look at the auto remediation part of
kpt. And once we have everything up and
running, we could just do one deployment,
send it all the way through production,
and then play a little bit with the
auto remediation parts where kpten is triggering Ansible
playbooks or feature flagging frameworks and these kind
of things. So to also see once it's
in production how how kpten can help.
Yeah. Definitely. We'll we'll start after after this.
But I think what we've shown today is
just the progressive delivery stuff is really good.
I hope people get an opportunity to play
with us, and we'll come back with more
episodes then. And and we'll take a look
at all those other features as well. So
thank you, Juergen, for joining me today. It
was really fun to kinda walk through this
and see how it all clicks together and
how it works. It's really cool software and
thanks for your efforts. Keep it up. I
will speak to soon. Thanks, David. Have a
nice day.
Thanks, everyone.